[Music]
isn't it it was very yeah we had all the
weather but it didn't matter anyway
rooms upstairs were lovely I went into
the bigger room which was my mistake
because the bridesmaids have got there
before me and there was just made up on
the floor in tents
I decided to have the other really big
nothing
does anyone of me the ceremony was
particularly nice the registrar's were
very helpful sort of the logistics of it
because there were quite a lot of people
in here it was a
and to have the extreme quartet outside
was lovely
because it's a an intimate venue you can
a string quartet outside and hear the
music in here beautifully fellow that
doesn't filter throughout the whole
house I think and in the aftermath
through entertainment in the garden
today and they played out there under
the tree what we see from the road is
just a fraction of what's actually here
so that's what's so nice about it I just
I just think the whole the whole setting
was was beautiful and from the goal to
actually come into to this room the
wedding the whole wood with the staff as
well the whole thing was just it was
just like being like from home to home
and it was really to me that was very
special
you didn't have to worry about anything
that took care of it we think and the
whole it was just a fantastic time and I
just really I was really impressed with
the way it all went in the setup thank
you for what we've done actually
brilliant but it was just it was just a
great time here
homeless really sounds good we had the
carriage that managed to get down beside
I mean that was there
like she took the elephants in me your
grandson they're all in there too right
down to PI [ __ ] which was absolutely
lovely I don't think they get in there
because it was quite a big carriage just
so good you know because the day was
such a sunny day it just had a hole full
of better our whole Rochford town and
the whole thing you know says we come
out with the horses and everything else
I think they want us waving to us
cheering which was quite nice really
under yeah we felt really good I think
it's the sort of place where you can
have something very small and located or
something slightly bigger and that I
think you've got the space to expend her
at the back and the to reception rooms
are lovely as well because lots of
people started offering that you know
how to read
yeah
[Music]
and I think the thing inked because it's
up under Kate this property from the
outside people didn't realize how lovely
it was you know what weren't you done to
it everything else the one was saying
even people come from Hampshire nothing
else was somewhat beautiful location I
didn't think it was going to be as as
nice as this for the goal and the room
itself in our oldies which is quite
there's a quite good - about their quite
a good experience for me particularly
our own giggles I've been here and
everything else that were not so that
was lovely really it's not very good we
had quite a few people who stayed over
and leaves the Holiday Inn they use the
Rochford hotel so there's lots of places
for them to stay or some people stayed
at being beans on the seafront nothing
is very very far away and they lost me
how far is this it's a short taxi ride
you
I've been thinking because because we're
local we wanted to use local like a
florist in our and the photography the
whole season everything we wanted it all
to be local really rather than come from
a distance and and they all did them
very cheap yeah
and that there were excellent every
every everyone from the safe and the
florist so that all everyone done
everything that we wanted to deserving
to be possible and they did it then he
signed up to go on until around Rochford
the you know the historical term which
actually I do recommend because it's
absolutely fantastic and I read some few
books about it but that he was gonna go
with another lady and debía cadencia mum
so she couldn't come so she said your
life to go which I did and I really
really enjoyed it and it was it was so
good and we ended back up this house but
the you know to actually come inside and
it was it was just fantastic the way
that they told us about the wall wasn't
happy now they used to live here
anything else so it was it was quite
nice when did he come out from her mom's
I said she she'd gone on them too as
their very good there's so much history
of Rochford is unbelievable but anyway
the funny thing is we were we on the
Sunday that you at the the wedding fair
assembly so
look at the house not thinking about the
wedding or the way you've there so we
just come in and then the girls will
bring them that they weren't this really
good and said you know you could get
married not engaged we wanted some
tradition a little bit you know but not
a tradition so relaxed and I think in
the service it was like that
you're quite a pan okay little little
teacups and won't forgot their little
colors with it their readings aren't
enemy yeah as they do be doing something
the funny thing is because it was so it
was so professionally done but it but it
was so laid back as well which is a
unusual sort of thing you know you
haven't got keep repeating and repeating
it it was lovely
because it all just flowed you know from
start to finish really and yeah do it
again practice practice once yeah you
want something
there's not a church wedding but Allah
this is not a registry office you've got
a little bit more than that because I
think the registry office is yeah we're
not lease enough that they do it very
professionally but you can't stay and
have a glass of champagne you come you
know have the kind of pace you can we
want her out into the government take
all your photographs it's it's a little
bit you know you could go somewhere else
to do that and I think was really really
nice to be here
I mean we could have got another
registry office years ago but we thought
no I won't fit especially we're not you
know church people so it had to be a you
know somewhere a bit different and and
then you're looking at hotels and we
didn't really want a hotel with it we
wanted something a little bit more
free-flowing a little bit more where we
could choose exactly what we wanted and
that's what we did
I think it would appeal to people of our
an angel or altar it would does that
thing youngsters and Weldon wanted a
sort of an intimate yes but wanted to go
somewhere else
love the space outside just say
that's good very good
you know people said that it has a
beautiful ear about pi seeing that like
you are sitting you're standing here and
it's got such a pleasure to be here
because there's so much history here you
know and and because watchman's got a
lot of history you're just a part of
that what you see from the outside is
disaffection of what you get from the
inside because I think people the kind
of traditional church wedding I've ever
been married before the kind of Patricia
traditional church because a lot of them
don't like you you know they won't give
them all the service so a lot of people
say yeah but go register office is like
you just sometimes just go to an office
and that's it it's just like an office
got an Okie and warp and that's done
we're I think this is this is this is
really good stuff how much not I make
but it's but it's a pleasure to be in
this place and I think it's and there's
something special about it that's what a
consistent can't believe words is
something special about it
so people are spoken to into the small
name now they're looking to come and
that they're waiting I did say they
don't have seen being like yeah we'd
recommend it for anyone who wants
some tradition mixed with a sort of an
informal atmosphere I think is an
absolute perfect mix
you
[Music]
you